we're gonna ask you questions about your
perfect my end up in tracing sounds
great yeah okay so if we were to have
like the ultimate couple your friends
around what first thing sighs what I'm a
big like chips and guacamole person like
I would love just like a giant bowl of
guacamole
um and then like drinks and tons of
drinks I am I know I really love like
ginger ale it's a really really specific
thing who would we invite we'd be like
your main do I pick like real people or
like Oh like celebrities are like oh my
god I would invite Beyonce but I don't
think she would come I think that she's
too busy who else I would really want
like Amy Poehler and Tina Fey I think
they would be so much fun we would just
like laugh at everything
I would like Jake Gyllenhaal because I
think he's dreaming
I feel like Adele I feel like she would
like have like a lot of like witty
comments and we would have a good time
it won't be wearing I'm all about like
comfort so like PJ old t-shirt
sweatpants socks have a blanket nearby a
great time what about the crazy
saying what would we do to like for the
pudding sleep definitely had like a big
like thermos of coffee nearby like sip
frequently good idea and then like
obviously like with Netflix there aren't
like commercial breaks but maybe like
during the intro like everybody run
around or like do jumping jacks yeah
well no you haven't breaking my sloth oh
yeah wake yourself up yeah we'd be doing
a beauty treatment oh yeah we would all
get like I don't know I'm not a fancy
person I like going to like CBS and like
picking up like the little face mask and
like I like to do those esse yeah I
would probably buy like a ton and we'd
all do face masks and it would be great
and what games I mean if I had like that
celebrity crew yes it would be like
truth or dare and it would be like never
have I ever and fun things I want to
know these people secret who are they
yeah okay who would we be stalking on
social media probably like all our exes
yeah like it's necessary sometimes you
just got to check what am i up to
yeah fine would we say I mean I am a
grandma and I love sleep but like I said
if I had like all those people in my
house I would say up as long as they
were willing to yeah okay that sounds
like a perfect night yeah thank you so
much oh yeah
[Music]